we study consumers interactions when
sharing the pursuit of the same goal
customers initially joined these
programs to work on goals their values
and to seek companionship from others
who are pursuing the same goal as a
result these consumers felt close and
shared helpful tips among the group
however we found that this companionship
does not last forever once people got
near their goal and felt more certain
about their ability to pursue this goal
themselves they stopped being friends
and stopped sharing information for
example we found that Weight Watchers
members who were successfully losing
weight started sitting at the back of
the room refused to participate in
discussions stop sharing their
experiences or dropped out of the
program altogether one solution for
marketers and organizations is to
emphasize to consumers the uncertainty
in how to approach the goal to test this
solution we designed a 7 day walking
program and found that when participants
thought that they were pursuing the
walking goal for different reasons than
their partner they felt less certain
about how to approach this goal and
consequently stay friendly helpful and
share tips until the end of the program
therefore if we could make people feel
that they are still unsure about how to
lose weight the best way to quit smoking
or how to earn more frequent flyer
mileage we can foster companionship and
facilitate knowledge exchange among
consumers this way knowledge information
and tools that can help consumers attain
their goals will be shared more widely
after all we are all in the same boat